Hey,
why is cracked so over the years you
guys know it's been our mission to use
the lens of philosophy,
literature,
and the humanities to achieve a greater
appreciation of art and hopefully to
enrich people's lives,
but today we're doing something a little
bit different.
This is ground zero of science content
on wisecracking.
For that I decided to bring on someone
who's a lot smarter than I am when it
comes to science.
Helen.
Hey guys.
So today we are starting with a wise
crack favorite to see if we can connect
some of the philosophical themes that we
talk about with existing research and
neuroscience,
biology and psychology.
So today we're starting with one punch
man.
Also want to give a quick shout out to
brilliant.org
for sponsoring this video.
Thank you guys.
So anyway,
I'm gonna.
Give it over to Helen.
Wait,
so is it hey wise crack Helen here.
So it would be.
Hey wisecrack held here.
You got to go.
It's one,
two,
three up,
down.
Hey.
Wise crack.
Helen here.
There we go.
Now say it faster.
Hey.
Wise,
crack Helen here and today we're putting
the boldest bad ass in the universe
under the microscope in one punch,
man.
Our protagonists site trauma is a salary
man turned hero who possesses no special
powers apart from the strength he's
gained through his intense training
regimen.
100 pushups,
100 sit ups and 100 squats that a 10
kilometer run.
Do it every single day,
and now he can defeat every enemy with a
single punch.
Sounds cool,
right?
Well,
this lack of challenge leave site to my
board,
detached and unfulfilled.
Oh they took was one punch.
Dreaming of becoming the best at
anything is pretty much being human one
on one,
but the site is dilemma.
Reflect our growing scientific
understanding of how humans can live a
satisfying life.
Welcome to this special wise crack
condition on the science of one punch
man,
and as always,
spoilers ahead with no real challenge.
Cytoma loses his enthusiasm for battle
much to the irritation of his rivals.
He blows them off.
Repairs to witness the true power.
I got dirt and my special pans place.
Hey,
are you even listening?
Insults them.
What a let down.
I was pretty excited to see the battle
suits I'd been hearing about,
but the design is pretty lame and all
they do is give you superhuman strength
and occasionally has the audacity to
yawn during a fight.
Does that really seem like sysomos
enjoying himself?
As we've mentioned before,
philosophers like Masa Hero Morioka have
argued that challenge is a necessary
component of a meaningful life,
and then as our lives become more
efficient and therefore less
challenging,
our mental health pays the price
we will continue to ride until food,
clothing,
and shelter are provided free of charge.
To those who do not work
sounds pretty boring.
It turns out this isn't just
philosophical.
Grandstanding science suggests there's a
biological basis for the idea.
The challenging ourselves is good for us
and it's not just our mental health
that's at stake.
If we always take it easy.
Neuroscientists,
Dr.
Mark Madsen argues that the
pervasiveness of what he calls
unchallenging lifestyles prevents us
from activating adaptive stress
responses.
A series of changes that take place at
the cellular level when an organism is
exposed to danger.
Here's how it works.
Let's say you're walking down the alley.
When you encounter a giant Kelp and
crusted monster,
your brain activates your sympathetic
nervous system or the part of the
nervous system that turns on the fight
or flight response by sending out a
molecule from the hypothalamus and
almond shaped area toward the center of
the brain.
This molecule tells the pituitary gland
to send out another molecule which sets
off a series of reactions in the adrenal
gland above the kidneys.
That ultimately leads to the release of
a substance called Cortisol,
Aka the stress hormone.
It's nickname comes from the fact that
it's the main hormone involved in the
stress response,
and while there's always a certain
baseline amount circulating through the
bloodstream,
those levels increase.
When your fight or flight response turns
up,
that extra quarters all prompts your
body to do things like break down sugar
to give you energy and numb the pain
response so you'd be more likely to
fight through an injury.
It also turns down the part of your
immune system that fights off viruses
and certain kinds of bacteria.
This isn't a bad thing.
The idea is to push the energy you need
to fight infection to other more
important tasks that'll help you survive
and immediate threat.
If this happens now and then it works,
kind of like endurance training,
your body learns how to respond to acute
stress more efficiently,
but if it's constant,
you can wind up with a botched immune
system as your body becomes less
sensitive to cortisol.
That can lead to chronic inflammation
because there's nothing stopping your
immune system from running on high,
which can lead to a host of other health
problems.
We might consider dominator of the
universe,
Lord boroughs,
as an exaggerated metaphor for this
process,
my species,
what the struggle for survival amid the
harsh environment of our home
repossessed,
the ultimate in regenerative ability
are you able to regrow entire limbs is a
pretty potent adaptive stress response.
A lot of the nuts,
so fictional starfish,
a well known limb regenerator Yep.
Burrells also points out that the
extreme strength he exudes and battle is
so taxing that it actually shortens his
life if he uses it.
Too often.
Doing this place is enormous stress on
my body.
Similar to anaerobic exercise,
as a result,
it's Jordan's my life,
the same
problem humans run into when our fight
or flight response goes into overdrive
for too long.
Scientists like Dr Mattson say humans
are evolutionarily adapted to deal with
environmental challenges and then not
having them on a regular basis,
mainly in the form of not enough
physical exertion or too little exposure
to the natural toxins found in plants
can lead to the prolonged inflammatory
states that have been linked to
everything from Alzheimer's to diabetes
to cancer.
Inflammation causes changes in DNA and
since DNA contains the code for creating
all the proteins in your body,
Wonky DNA can result in misshape and
proteins.
Those can go on to screw up hormone
regulation and encourage out of control
cell growth.
In other words,
cancer from Dr Matson's perspective
without challenges,
your body isn't given opportunities to
strengthen its defenses that is improved
the adoptive stress response,
so when something starts to go wrong,
it has a hard time fixing it.
Outside of the physical effects,
a lack of conflict introduces a similar
logic.
Operates psychologically will cite them
or may not be getting diabetes.
He's probably got some issues going on
in his brain parts through the show.
We can see how enduring challenges can
make you more mentally resilient.
Let's take genos.
He's faced certain challenges that to
hasn't faced on what we know from the
show site has had it pretty easy.
He didn't get into the crime fighting
business to avenge the death of his
family or bring justice to the
oppressed.
He just did it for fun fast one.
Who are you?
Just a guy who's a hero for fun.
On the other hand,
genesis backstory is much more
traumatic.
He witnessed the destruction of his
hometown and the death of his family at
the hands of an out of Control Cyborg.
We lived a peaceful and happy life
together until that fateful day when a
crazy cyborg went out of control and
attacked our town.
His experience mirrors that of many
other characters in the genre.
Gods from Berzerk Aaron from attack on
Titan Naruto.
A painful childhood is a common
denominator throughout anime,
Manga and comics in general.
So how did these experiences shape the
characters?
Well,
it's pretty complex and often a little
stuck on one hand their struggles
motivate them or at the very least seem
to give them the strength to withstand
extremely difficult circumstances.
Psychology backs this up.
A growing body of research suggests that
some people who go through adverse or
traumatic experiences as kids are in
some ways more resilient than those
whose childhoods were relatively
carefree.
For instance,
some individuals who grow up in high
stress environments develop unique
problem solving skills and are better
able to deal with uncertainty and their
peers who had it easier.
Of course,
that doesn't change the fact that there
are loads of other issues associated
with having a rough childhood like
problems with learning and memory and a
propensity for being emotionally
reactive and there are caveats to the
whole what doesn't kill you,
makes you stronger idea to research on
adults has indicated that those who face
the medium number of challenging life
events like the death of a loved one or
financial difficulties or better able to
cope with worry and stress than those
who deal with either an unusually low or
an unusually high number of such
experiences.
It sort of like the goldilocks
principle.
Optimal adaptation distress is achieved
from not having too much exposure,
but not too little either.
In theory,
general says,
traumatic experiences may have boosted
his ability to handle the emotional
whiplash of hero work.
There'll being a cyborg definitely
helps.
He fights to near death in battle and
shows up when others don't like when the
s class heroes are called in to hold off
the media that threatens to wipe out
cities eat.
Meanwhile,
Cytoma meanders through life.
He can't even try to swat a mosquito
without losing it.
Additionally,
having something to strive for the
coming is powerful.
SSNC gives genesis work,
meaning a stark contrast with Cytoma who
was already at the top of his game.
I'd always dreamed of becoming some,
what is this?
What's wrong with me?
Why does my heart feel so lifeless and
empty?
What site to be more satisfied if he had
something more meaningful to work
towards.
Then some bs,
superhero classification,
and what's the purpose of having a
purpose anyway?
Is there some kind of biological benefit
to leading a meaningful life?
Back in 2008,
team of researchers published a study on
the Japanese concept of picky guy,
which roughly translates to a reason for
being in it.
They asked 43,000
people a simple question,
do you have achy guide in your life?
By the end of the seven year long study,
roughly 95 percent of those who
reporting having a sense of icky guy,
we're still alive compared to only 83
percent of those who said they did not,
regardless of socioeconomic status,
psychological factors,
lifestyle,
or history of illness,
the increased mortality risk remained.
Most of those who died without a sense
that they could guide did so as a result
of heart disease,
mainly strokes for context.
A link between heart disease and a lack
of purpose has shown up consistently in
other studies.
Uh,
2015 roundup of Japanese and American
research on the topic been reduced heart
disease and those who reported having a
sense of meaning in life.
Unlike the villains in the series who
often have rather legitimate reasons for
wanting to destroy humanity
in order to wipe out humanity.
Medieval civilization surface given bond
Cytoma
is still unsure of is icky guy.
How do you even have purpose when you've
achieved what people like Genos can only
dream of is aimless existence,
leaves him prone to depression,
irritability,
and melancholy.
Fluoros has struggled to find his icky
guy to his purpose in life was to
destroy one world after the next what?
After growing so strong that he no
longer had worthy adversaries,
he found himself board and apathetic a
car,
told him he could find the opponent that
would reignite his passion for battle,
so he's been traveling for 20 years to
find one when he encounters cytoma.
In a sense sight.
Tma Is [inaudible] ag guy and give
stimulation to my existence.
Scientists for years have postulated a
relationship between purpose,
life satisfaction and resilience.
Back in 1946,
Dr.
Viktor Frankl,
a psychiatrist,
neurologist,
and Holocaust survivor suggested that
the societal ills of aggression,
addiction,
and depression stemmed from an
existential vacuum or the idea that
one's life and work much purpose in his
book.
Man's search for meaning.
He describes the psychological impact of
daily life in a Nazi concentration camp.
He knows that the prisoners who clung
onto a sense of purpose,
we're the ones most likely to survive
writing life has never made unbearable
by circumstances,
but only by lack of meaning and purpose.
Since then,
we've seen over and over again that
having no sense of meaning in life is
associated with a higher risk of
addiction,
anxiety and depression.
On the flip side,
having a sense of purpose is associated
with lower incidents of these issues.
If challenging one's self is key to
finding purpose in life and having sort
of purpose is necessary for optimal
psychological and perhaps even physical
health can,
we can see why having virtually no
competition leave site to a miserable,
challenging ourselves can help us find
that meaning and improves our wellbeing
in other ways too,
and in some cases even the hardships we
can't control can make us more
resilient,
which suggests there might be a
psychological benefit to seeing them as
an opportunity for growth.
So we'll cite them to ever be presented
with a real challenge.
I wonder if taking out this guy will
count as work and if he does will it
gives him a much needed sense of
passion.
We'll just have to wait until season two
whenever that is to find out and just to
make sure you're being challenged.
I'm going to put my money where my mouth
is and give you a brain teaser courtesy
of brilliant.org.
Imagine you're presented with five
chocolates to choose from,
one of which is poison.
You alternate turns with an opponent and
during each turn,
the current player must choose whether
to eat one or two of the remaining
chocolates.
The player who eats the poisoned
chocolate uses.
If you're the first player,
what moves should you make each turn to
when to find out the solution and to
find more awesome logic puzzles.
Go to brilliant.org/wise
crack or click the link in the
description.
It's free to sign up and they'll email
you the solution.
Work out your brain with their fun
arcade style puzzles.
Personally,
I love the calculus module,
which is a miracle because,
well,
it's calculus,
but brilliant actually made it fun.
Anyway,
go check it out.
If you're one of the first 200 people to
click on the link,
you'll get 20 percent off in annual
subscription.
All right.
Wow.
So that's one video down.
So what'd you guys think?
Drop me a line in the comments.
Did you guys like it?
Hate it.
Do you Miss Jared?
You Miss Jared,
don't you fine.
Here he is.
Banks.
Helen,
I just wanted to say that that's enough.
See you guys around.